we're back with Dan Souza straight from
America's Test Kitchen and the editor-in
chief of one of my favorite magazines in
the world Cooks Illustrated I mean that
is an institution Dan yeah it's an honor
to to be at the helm of it yeah you are
yes no it really is and and it's for
awesome recipes but it's also for really
cool kitchen hacks we spend so much time
testing these figuring out new stuff and
and it's not everything that you've like
seen it on the Internet it's like really
new great content you have one that I
have never heard of and I can't unsee it
take it away D teach us the way this one
here yeah I I this is a mind blower for
me so we're really big about cutting
back on food waste and just waste in
general I think a lot of people are at
this point and so when you're Rising
Do's it's one thing where like you
always reach for the plastic wrap
because you need that pretty tight seal
to trap moisture in there so that it
rises nicely plastic wrap obviously
single use not great no okay so I have a
really great solution and a very fun
solution and that is actually shower
caps so brilliant is says they're in the
shape of the bowl they're in the shape
of the bowl so big key thing is you want
to get clean ones right you want to get
fresh clean ones right not out of the
shower not out of the shower unless
you're really comfortable with your
dough and your family but I think it's
great to get a fresh one and what's
amazing is yes they're the shape of the
bowl they go right over the top they
seal perfectly and you can you can reuse
it endlessly over and over and over
again like never again Dan never again
never again guess guess and if you buy
yeah if you buy a bunch you can you can
pose with your color
coordinate yeah you can color coordinate
it's like it's perfect right buy some
fun ones I think that's the key bit all
right Dan what's next what else other
mindblowing things you brought okay so
the next one I'm should I take this off
to this one we're on to the next one
okay so for the next one here this is a
really simple tip about grating cheese
when you're getting you know a lot for
pizza or nachos that sort of thing one
of the biggest things that happens is
you you run the cheese on here it's soft
and it just sticks and it makes it
really hard to get all the cheese yes so
a super simple step is to start with a
cooking spray like this right and just
give it a quick dusting on there so then
when you go see the reaction is there
you go look I love when you guys freak
out about something because I'm usually
the one freaking out and I feel like
such solidarity with everybody right now
so it just it just goes right off and it
makes it so you can get right to the end
of it and you canay not stuck on there
yeah and you can respray like you know
if you're doing a ton of cheese just do
that and it and it really makes a big
difference it also keeps it separated
nicely cuz you have that little bit of
oil coating everything it's brilliant
Dan super simple one all right teach me
how to crack an egg I make them every
morning every morning yes and I
literally I'm a bad cracker you're a bad
cracker I don't oh you know what I'm
sorry we're actually going to go to a
commercial break and then I even brought
video of me like trying to sh and we'll
be right
[Music]
back